E aí
os ingredientes entrevista nova técnica
a gente tem que fazer uma sala para
defender ele funciona cruzamento e daí
ficaram super felizes que no mundo há
e como navegar estou aqui na frente
Caçador muito bonito quando entrei na
programação bonita de 2002 eu não
imaginava que eu ia cair veículos
permitem seguinte com os cenários como
as identidades
e eu não tenho aquele produto então no
sábado tem que ser uma reclamar
preenchimento tá aqui Valeu até ele vem
sofrendo com os ataques nos últimos
tempos mas Brincadeiras à parte a gente
precisa conversar sobre até quando a
gente vai continuar tolerando o
intolerável Por que os cortes na
educação não são de hoje eles já vem
acontecendo há décadas e tanto o
dinheiro que aí destinado à educação e à
saúde para esse país vem servindo como
barganha para esse e outros governos
sempre tentarem tirar o Brasil da crise
alguma crise precisa tirar daqui retirar
de educação
e esse ano em abril de 2019 foi
anunciado um contingenciamento de 5,8
bilhões de reais
e esse disco de dinheiro é destinado
desde o ensino básico até o ensino
superior uma faixa de pedestre orçamento
de 1,7 bilhões seria destinado aos
institutos e universidades federais EA
partir desse lugar que eu falo porque
ali que eu tô inserida
a todos esses anúncios de cortes criaram
um clima de tensão e de ameaça as
pessoas começaram a achar que
universidade a ser fechada que ia faltar
luz que a falta a água EA gente começou
o primeiro semestre de 2019 nesse clima
no dia quinze de maio quando as notícias
eclodiram eclodiram também as
manifestações na rua e mais de 200
cidades tiveram essas ruas invadidas
pela voz estudantil no chamado tsunami
da Educação
E desde o início do ano a Universidade
Federal de Santa Catarina Os estudantes
da Universidade Federal de Santa
Catarina tanto degradação quando
pós-graduação começaram a se envolver em
uma série de atividades como UFSC na
praça O objetivo dessa ação era mostrar
um pouquinho do que que a gente faz
dentro dos muros da academia tirando
essa produção de dentro desse
academicismo que a gente reconhece que é
dura que também precisa ser repensado e
levando isso para fora para as
comunidades
É mas esse tipo de ação infelizmente não
foi suficiente
em alguns que recebeu um corte de trinta
por cento ou seja 46 milhões esse número
parece sempre muito distante e às vezes
é difícil materializar O que que
significa um na prática esses cortes
é bom a décima oitava sepex teve que ser
cancelada um evento de mostra de todas
as pesquisas que eram eram realizadas
dentro da Universidade extremamente
importante para que estudantes de ensino
médio e Fundamental de escolas públicas
e municipais fossem visitar a
universidade estivesse em contato com a
produção científica interna esse evento
não aconteceu mas Em contrapartida
aconteceu Graphics
o 93 funcionários terceirizados
precarizar os terceirizados foram
demitidos entre funcionários
responsáveis pela limpeza e segurança do
campus algumas pessoas acham que isso é
pouco mas se antes a gente tinha três
pessoas para limpar um banheiro um
prédio inteiro agora a gente tem uma
as bolsas de ensino pesquisa e extensão
começaram a sumir serem suspensas
congeladas e é bem assim sumir o
professor vai lá entra no sistema e hoje
o sistema está fora do ar ele não
consegue cadastrar um novo estudante
para receber Aquela bolsa que tinha
ficado vaga E essa bolsa não volta
E essas informações são importantes
porque eu entendo que isso é a
precarização do ensino é a precarização
das condições materiais necessárias para
que a gente possa fazer pesquisa ensino
e extensão o pensamento pesa a gente
também tem fome a gente também precisa
de condições materiais para poder fazer
ciência
bom e se engana muito quem acha que a
universidade pública tá cheia de filho
de riquinha de Riquinho porque não é
essa na verdade mais de setenta por
cento dos graduandos vêm de famílias com
renda per capita de até um salário
mínimo e meio dados de 2018
e em setembro de 2019 quando a gente
voltou das aulas em agosto foi anunciado
que o restaurante universitário teria
condições de funcionar só até dia quinze
de Setembro essa informação mais o
acumulado de tensão que a gente já vinha
recebendo ao longo do ano fez com que o
movimento estudantil eclodisse e mais de
quatro mil pessoas lotaram o maior
auditório guarapuvu eu não consegui tá
lá dentro para fazer essa foto eu tava
do lado de fora fiquei com medo porque
tinha muita gente muita gente eu nunca
tinha visto um movimento estudantil tão
forte assim na minha atuação
e logo em seguida nos dias dez e onze de
setembro foram realizadas assembleias
dos Estudantes de graduação e
pós-graduação e a gente declarou greve a
partir de agora eu vou falar mais na
experiência enquanto uma estudante de
pós-graduação que fez greve enquanto
fazia sua dissertação de Mestrado porque
numa época em que o fazer científico vem
sendo atacado a gente entende que não é
possível para as nossas pesquisas fazer
pesquisa se tornou político extremamente
político significa se posicionar a favor
do fazer científico
bom então a gente continua trabalhando
se reunindo e fazendo uma série de
atividades no início é o mesmo eu não
tinha certeza se greve era melhor
alternativa para esse cenário mas na
medida que as coisas foram evoluindo e
eu fui vendo aquela massa coletiva de
estudantes e conhecendo um monte de
rosto de outros pós graduandos de outras
informações que eu nunca tinha visto eu
acabei me envolvendo cada vez mais
é nessas horas a gente sempre fica em
dúvida se a gente vai paralisar ou se a
gente vai lutar porque a gente se
pergunta se a gente vai ter condições de
continuar estudando
e com o presente desmoronando que futuro
Sobra para achar que amanhã vai ser
melhor
é a vida de pesquisador e pós-graduando
requerem uma série de concessões e
desafios todo mundo sabe que
Florianópolis é uma cidade extremamente
cara se a gente quer fazer dedicação
exclusiva para pesquisa já é bastante
difícil sobreviver com r$ 1500 que a
bolsa do mestrado ou 2200 reais que a
bolsa doutorado se a gente não tiver nem
esse financiamento o que vai acontecer é
que as Universidades ao invés de se
tornarem mais plurais vão continuar
sendo destinada somente a uma elite
branca e não é isso que a gente quer
é mas como em meio ao caos só não pode o
desespero é melhor lutar ao invés de
paralisar
a e é por isso que a gente entrou em
greve e se engana muito quem pensa que
greve é para ficar em casa foram 40 dias
insanos extremamente cansativos com
atividades pulverizados pelo câmpus
inteiros aulas abertas atividades na rua
panfletagem ação em mídias sociais uma
série de reuniões para fazer análise de
conjuntura Assembleia para fazer debate
bom a gente aprender você acolher
é isso a gente abriu a boca para pedir a
restituição da verba orçamentária desse
ano a gente resolveu que na verdade a
gente pedir era mais por exemplo a
revisão da lei orçamentária de 2020
porque é verdade que ao longo do ano o
governo foi liberando algumas verbas e
não foi contingenciado inteiramente
aqueles 1,7 milhões mas se engana quem
acha que as coisas ficaram estáveis o
projeto de lei orçamentária de 2020
ainda pior e vai ser ainda mais Cruel
além disso a gente resolveu pedir o
arquivamento da da minuta futuro se a
gente pediu o resto o reajuste
retroativo de bolsas de Mestrado a gente
pediu o aumento de oferta de bolsa de
mestrado e doutorado pensando em
políticas de inclusão de estudantes
negros indígenas e quilombolas
nós pedimos a manutenção das bolsas de
gente de pesquisa arquivamento da
reforma da Previdência e principalmente
a revogação da emenda constitucional o
teto de gastos dos ataques 95
e no final dos 40 dias a vida de
Mestrando a grevista estava Impossível a
gente já tava doente cansado fizemos
várias rodas de conversa de acolhimento
mas a gente foi reconhecendo aqui como a
une a união nacional dos Estudantes nem
aapg Associação Nacional dos
pós-graduandos e nem os professores da
UFSC aderiram à greve a gente foi
obrigado a reconhecer que a gente tava
sendo isolado ao invés de chamar em uma
greve nacional essas instituições
chamaram a paralisação de dois dias nos
dias dois e Três de Outubro depois disso
a sensação que eu tive quando eu voltei
para o campus era como se tudo tivesse
terminado
bom então a gente teve que fazer uma
assembleia e sair da greve
E é claro que greve não é solução
definitiva mas ela acaba sendo uma
resposta imediata para cenários
insustentáveis e se engana muito quem
acha que todo mundo sai perdendo com a
greve Eu discordo eu acho que essa greve
teve pontos muito positivos e importante
o principal deles foi aprender a se
posicionar numa época não é porque a
gente debate demais pelas redes sociais
pelas telas de celular e não olha mais
Olho no Olho fazer uma assembleia e
resgatar o significado político do que
que significa sentar em roda olhar ou no
olho aprender a debater e discordar foi
extremamente importante as assembleias
existem justamente para isso até mesmo
para alguém ir lá e chamar o fim da
greve como aconteceu além disso um saldo
extremamente importante foi aprender a
reconhecer os olhos de quem luta em lado
a lado
É muita gente não sabe mas a vida
acadêmica de pós graduando pode ser
extremamente atomizante isoladora e a
gente vai ficando cada vez mais isolado
nas nossas pesquisas e acaba perdendo as
vezes o contato em relações com algumas
pessoas então reconhecer que você não
está sozinho na luta que você pode
conhecer olhar Olho no olho e se acolher
isso foi extremamente importante
é mas agora que eu já apresentei para
vocês o que que aconteceu nesses 40 dias
da UFSC que foram bastante insanos foi
só um gostinho eu queria debater algumas
questões um pouco mais importantes
emergência porque eu entendi que os
cortes na educação Na verdade era um só
um arranhão perto de coisas outras que a
gente precisa de bater a gente tá
falando de projetos de vida quando a
gente fala de ensino superior e acesso
ao ensino superior a gente tem que
lembrar que ainda existem nesse país
muitas pessoas que estão as vezes as
primeiras de uma família acessar o
ensino superior como você seiva a
educação você tá aceitando o projeto de
vida não só dessa pessoa mas daquela
família inteira que vinha na educação
como uma promessa de avanço social
um acordo com a gente está lidando com
problemas complexos estruturais a gente
vive sob o regime de um sistema
neoliberal extremamente individualista e
individualizante que não pesa quase nada
pelo coletivo
e a gente tá com os mundos em ruínas o
nosso fazer científico tá prejudicado
a e é por isso que eu ainda continuo
apostando e acreditando que a
Universidade São vidas em ebulição são a
possibilidade de um espaço de fazer
contraponto a esse desmonte que vem
acontecendo Eu particularmente
vestidinho entra na pós graduação porque
eu desejo ser professora e diante desse
cenário vários dos meus colegas assim
como eu nos vimos perguntando várias
vezes que eu vou fazer da vida vai ter
universidade para trabalhar depois vou
continuar estudando
e eu prefiro acreditar que sim eu ainda
prefiro acreditar que a possibilidade de
uma universidade ainda abre caminhos
ainda abre pensamentos
é porque a gente não tá lá para ser
formado enquanto um tarefista
qualificado a gente não entra numa
universidade só para aprender uma
técnica para executar segundo as lógicas
do mercado a gente entra lá para
aprender a pensar para entrar em contato
com o plural com o diferente com outras
pessoas outras realidades
e a gente entra na universidade para
fazer perguntas melhores
é óbvio que a gente não tem resposta
para vários dos problemas que estão
sendo aqui colocados e é por isso que a
gente precisa ainda mais de educação
porque a gente vai precisar ainda mais
de estudo para conseguir sair desse
buraco que a gente vem se metendo e é
por isso que eu defendo uma educação que
seja pública gratuita diversa plural de
qualidade que atendam os interesses da
população Esse hoje eu tenho alguma
intenção de deixar alguma mensagem para
vocês aqui é que a gente possa continuar
defendendo isso de modo coletivo porque
defendeu uma universidade Não é só para
quem tá lá dentro e nem muito menos só
para quem deseja fazer carreira dentro
da Universidade ela é um centro de
pensamento importante para a sociedade
como um todo
E como diria Ariano Suassuna eu poderia
ser uma última está tola ou uma
pessimista chata mas acho que eu prefiro
ainda tem uma Realista esperançosa e
acreditar na força do coletivo para o
mundo melhor e eu espero que todos vocês
venham comigo junto defender educação
desse país obrigado a